okay by my watch I make it time so thank
you very much for coming along I know
it's the last talk of the day so I
suspect everyone is now quite tired seen
quite a lot of talks quite a lot
technical content and have probably just
hanging around because there's beer
later but thank you very much for coming
whatever your reasons my name is Steve
I'm a senior developer
for a company called magics so we're
based down in Brighton and we do suffer
as a service recruitment products
primarily so products to engage
recruiters and employers with the right
professional audiences I'm also a
Microsoft MVP and I run a small meetup
group down in Brighton called net
southeast which we we host out of the
magics offices I also have a blog so if
you want to find out any more
information about some of the stuff I'm
going to cover
I have blogged quite extensively about I
hate to be client factory and some of
the features there so if there's
anything that you sort of you think I go
over too quickly you can find full code
samples of a lot of the the things I
will show you there and if you ever have
questions and in the future please do
reach out to me on Twitter that's DJ
Gordon so oh and one of the thing to
point out I have put the link there to
the slide so a lot a lot of people take
pictures of slides and go through the
talk but you don't have to they're all
online already so just make sure you've
got a picture of this slide and then
you're good to go for the rest so the
topic of this talk is kind of HTTP
making HTTP requests in dotnet core and
the reason that I feel this is a really
interesting time to start talking about
this stuff is that more and more of us
are building micro services and smaller
services that are communicating with one
another and quite often there are some
real-time needs so we're going to use
HTTP to make those requests and so
because we're now doing this more often
this is quite a vital part of our
application code to make sure that we're
doing it in the most correct way that we
can to get the best performance that we
can and to make sure that we're not
going to stumble into any roadblocks so
basically in this talk we're going to
take some code and we're going to
refactor it through the rest of the hour
to subtly improve it as we go the RHIB
app let's talk HTTP
so just to set the scene just to make
sure everyone's expectations are kind of
correct as to what we're going to cover
in this talk we're going to talk about
IHT client factory which is a new
feature that came out in dotnet core 2.1
we're going to talk about why we need
that to begin with so what are the some
potential pitfalls that you may run into
before using I HTTP client factory and
therefore what why has it been
introduced in the first place we'll talk
about how to use it we'll look at simple
examples to begin with or just kind of
converting existing code in the simplest
way we can and then we will slowly add
more and more features and layers in
from the IH to be for factory Klein set
we're going to talk a little bit about
this concept of outgoing middleware how
many people in this room is p.net core
developers already ok good number so
you'll be familiar with the concept of
middleware to bring your request into
your application in asp.net core and
it's kind of how we have all
cross-cutting concerns and requirements
in in those applications just as we can
have incoming middleware for requests
that come into the application we can
have this same kind of concept with
requests that we're making from our
applications and this is a good place to
do kind of cross-cutting concerns if you
have logging requirements or you want to
do any kind of metrics and monitoring of
your requests using this concept of
essentially middleware is a great way to
do that we're also going to talk a
little bit about a library called poly
and how this can be linked with our HTTP
current factory to help us make our
requests more resilient and to make our
code better unable to handle transient
type problems how many people were in
Brian's talk before this one on poly ok
about half so we will kind of skim over
poly but if you want any more
information about it I recommend you
check out the recording of Brian's talk
as well where he can go into much more
detail on these things we'll talk a
little bit about patterns and some
recommendations I have to work them I
hate to be client and then just
generally some other improvements in
dotnet core 2.1 that are worth noting I
am generally speaking about dotnet core
today there were some differences
between what's available in dotnet core
and dotnet framework I'm generally
speaking about dotnet core so we're
going to start with this piece of code
spoiler alert there are some issues
this cave but we're going to start with
this because this sort of represents
what you may see in in traditional
applications today so this is just a
controller and we've got an action
method on here and in there what we're
going to do is we're going to make a
call to the github API because we want
to get some data that we're going to
shape into our own object model and then
we're going to return it now before I
move on how many people have kind of got
code like this in their code bases today
or a single code like this and I sort of
vaguely familiar with this okay cool so
we're going to look at some issues with
this code we're going to look at some
potential pitfalls and hopefully start
to factor those out the first piece of
wants to start with is this using
statement here so we've got a using
statement over there HTTP client because
htb fine implements eye disposable that
seems perfectly reasonable because we've
kind of all habit drummed into us that
if you're working with something that is
a disposable you should dispose of it
when you're done and we are done with it
as far as we're concerned at the end of
this request but there are some risks
and issues with this when we create a
h-2b client we get a HTTP message
handler chain and this is the handler
chain that's ultimately going to be
responsible for at some point
establishing a connection to an endpoint
somewhere that we're making this request
to when we dispose of the HTTP client we
dispose of that underlying handler chain
and then we dispose or we would release
the connection that we we were using
that might be okay if we were running
this once maybe just as a start up for
our application but here we've got it on
an action method and this could be
called 10 20 times a minute a second
depending on the load on our own website
and so this piece of code could be also
scattered across many other actions and
so what we're doing in this scenario is
we're creating many HTTP clients many
HTTP handler chains underneath there and
any connection pools that are going to
be opened and closed very rapidly the
risk of this is that we can run into a
situation where we run out of sockets on
the machine because the way the TCP spec
is defined is that when we actively
close the connection it doesn't
immediately release the port so that
it's available again for the OS to
allocate to other processes it will go
into what's called a time weight State
typically on Windows that's about two
40 seconds and during that time wait
state that port is basically just
sitting there it sits there because it's
not gonna be allocated to other
processes that may need to make our own
connections just in case there's any
latent packets that are still working
their way across the network because of
this that port is tied up for four
minutes and we have a situation where if
we do this frequently we're just going
to sit with many many ports sitting in
this time weight state unnecessarily
this is kind of what that looks like so
I took that piece of code and just chuck
it it chucked it into a loop and ran it
20 times to my blog so on the left-hand
side here you can see I've got 20
different ports that ended up getting
used on my local machine all talking to
my website all sat in this time weight
state and they're just basically wasted
at this point and the situation that we
can run into is if we do this enough and
we exhaust all of the sockets then our
application cannot make any outgoing
connections at this point and the server
that we're running Ison it's affecting
all other applications on that server as
well there are no spare ephemeral ports
to use there's around 16,000 ephemeral
ports roughly on Windows give or take
but if you've got enough of that code
that's just kind of dropping in these
connections very often you can exhaust
that pretty quickly you will see that as
a socket exhausting exception in your
application so what's the solution to
that
well the recommendation up to the
release of dotnet core 2.1 and asp.net
core 2.1 was to try and avoid
continually creating and disposing of
HTTP client that was the simplest
solution because it means we create the
HTTP client and then we keep it around
for a period of time and then we use the
same connections that we've already
established this is some benefits
because there's a small performance hit
from establishing connections and doing
TLS handshakes that we don't have to
kind of keep taking the hit on as well
and ultimately that's going to improve
our application right so what we can do
to achieve that there's various ways you
might want to do it you might want to
make this kind of a static HTML and on
some of your classes or you may want to
make it a singleton typically what I
would have done is just register this in
DI so this is my startup class I've got
a configure services method in
I can set up my dependency injection
container and I would just register a
HTTP client instance in there as a
singleton and this means that I can
inject it where I need to and I will get
the same instance time and time again so
if I were to update my controller now to
take advantage of this first I would add
a constructor here accepting my H to be
client from the dependency injection
container and then I could update my
code little I don't need to create my
own client anymore I'm going to use that
singleton instance that's going to be
created once for the lifetime of the
application so I can go into my using
statement now one thing I was doing in
the previous code was I was setting some
default headers on the client so that
all requests through that client in this
case just one request would have these
default headers applied with the
singleton HTTP client approach there's a
bit of a risk to this it is Fredd safe
but there are some properties along like
that width there aren't the default
headers and the base address there are
some examples of that changing these
could have have effect on other
components that are using this shared
HTTP client instance that's an easy fix
for now I'll just move those to the
request and set them on the request per
request basis and then finally I open up
my to update my code to use that
singleton HTTP client instance but
unfortunately software often has a butt
and there is a butt to this with this
approach we've created that single h-2b
client and we're sharing it for the life
of the application and this means that
any connections we establish will try
and live for the lifetime of the
application as well the issue with that
is that when we first establish a
connection to API github.com for example
we're going to do a DNS lookup to get an
IP address of a server to speak to and
once we've got that we can establish the
connection but that that IP address may
not exist there forever
particularly in cloud environments
things come and go and typically DNS is
now used as a way of switching around
those services the biggest problem would
come from an example of maybe using a
Bluegreen deployment so if you're
talking to a service that uses that
approach maybe like as your web slots
you might have a production and staging
slot live at the same time and it's just
DNS which is directing traffic to the
correct production instance but if we've
established that connection to
production and then someone does a
deployment and the DNS is used to switch
what is considered the
reduction live copy we may be now
talking to the wrong instance so having
these connections open permanently is
kind of better from the exotic
exhaustion point of view but not great
from the point of view that we're now
not honoring DNS in any way and that's
kind of where httpclient factory comes
to the rescue
it was designed with various things in
mind but one of the main things that is
going to offer us is that it's going to
manage the lifetime at those HTTP
message handler chains and it's
ultimately than those that are hanging
on to the connection so it does that by
basically holding on to a pool of these
connections and it will keep them alive
by default for two minutes and so all
the while it's handing out HTTP client
instances it will use the same handler
chain in the same connection as long as
those haven't expired at the time that
two minute runs out it kind of just puts
it into an expired pool and means that
it won't be issued to any new HTTP
client instances so this kind of gives
us the best of both we're holding on to
connections for long enough that we're
not going to continually create ports
and open ports that are then going to
sit in this time light state but we're
refreshing periodically to ensure that
we do pick up changes that might occur
by closing and reopening those
connections and that that two minutes is
configurable so if you know that the
downstream system might change more
often than you could shorten that life
or you can make it longer if you want to
the other things it does is it provides
a central location for configuring kind
of logical HTTP client instances so we
can set up different configurations HTTP
clients that we may need in our
application for dealing with different
services and endpoints and then we can
use those at will and we'll see examples
of two ways of doing that
it also codifies the concept of that
outgoing middleware idea that I talked
about so we could always achieve
outgoing middleware or the concept of it
using delegating handlers these have
been around with HTTP client forever but
to set those up and then to pass them
into the HP client took a little bit of
manual work with HTTP client factory a
lot of that can be moved away now and we
can just use some fluent configuration
methods to start applying cross-cutting
concerns using these handlers in our
code and it also integrates with poly as
I said earlier so this gives us the
possibility of very easily wrapping our
cause
in policies that will handle transient
situations for us so we can try and make
our application resilient to failures
downstream to services that are coming
and going
particularly cloud environments where
you know things are being deployed very
often and there may be short switchovers
between services it makes sense to try
and handle those situations and not just
fail immediately if something's not
around for the first time we try to talk
to it and it offers initially some basic
diagnostics and logging and it does this
using the asp.net core logging feature
and you can turn this on if you want to
see all of the requests that are being
made through anything managed by HTTP
client factory you can even get timings
and details about the headers that were
being sent out on this request if you
need to so let's start with converting
that code that we had so that we can
move over to HTTP client factory and
what we're going to do here is we're
going to do this in the simplest way
possible
so this isn't taking advantage of
necessarily all the features of HTTP
client factory to begin with but this is
to kind of demonstrate that the least
work that you could do to take an
existing application that where you were
managing your own lifetime hated should
be client yourself and actually do that
through HTTP client factory so in my
startup class I've got this ad singleton
HP client that we'd been using a minute
ago I'm gonna get rid of this now and
instead I'm going to use the add heat to
decline extension method on the I
service collection so this is just
provided by the library this will be
available to you if you're using asp.net
core 2.1 or above it's included in the
all the asp.net core app Venessa package
if you're using just dotnet core 2.1 and
you want to bring this in you can bring
in the microsoft or extension so HTTP
package and then you can start using
this in kind of like generic host kind
of situations as well so this will
register the services we need and that
will do for now so we'll move over to
the convertor controller again and the
first change is to adjust the
constructor we're not going to inject
HTTP client now we're going to inject
the HTTP client factory so now this will
give us a factory that can give us the
HTTP client we want to use then we can
make a change down here so
we're taking advantage of that and we're
just going to use the factory to create
a client so we'll call create client
behind the scenes the factory will
create a brand new HTTP client every
time so we can guarantee it's a unique
instance for us but what it will do is
reuse that existing handler chain if one
already exists that hasn't yet expired
otherwise it will just create a new
handler chain and pass it in to us so
this means that we don't have to worry
about the the connection lifetime there
and now we can just use that local
instance so that's kind of the
bare-bones and there's very minimal work
there to go through an existing
application and just start swapping out
instances where maybe you were
registering htb client in DI or doing
some other mechanism to create it and
that will kind of give you initially
without very little work the the
lifetime management feature so that
you're now getting that connection
management but where HP client factory
starts to get more powerful is we is if
we start to take advantage of things
like named clients and later type typed
clients will start with names because
they're a little bit simpler to
understand and named clients is one of
the first ways that we can create this
kind of logical configuration for a
client so instead of just calling add
h-2b client here I'm now going to call
this additional overload that lets me
specify a named client now this is one
logical configuration I could register
many of these one after the other to
create different configurations for
different services I'm talking to in
this case I've named this one github
because it deals with the the github API
and then I can pass in this action if I
want to that will allow me to configure
the client so when the factory creates
the new client before it hands it back
to us it will run this this delegate and
this allows us to set things like the
base address and default headers in one
place because we're getting a new
instance every time we ask for one we
can be assured that we're not going to
have to worry about sharing this across
thread because we should just be using
the client and then forgetting about it
the reason it's nice is set them here is
I'm setting these once so anything that
uses this named client it's now going to
apply this base address and default
headers if these change I have one place
to change them and that's that's kind of
nice so what date our code we're going
to make a few changes now in this
controller so the URL I was previously
using I can shorten just to the path
because again we're using that base
address so if that does change hopefully
if the path stays the same
we're okay this doesn't have to adjust
and this request headers that I was now
adding and I would have to remember to
do this in every place I was making the
request I can get rid of because now
that's going to be given to me on the
client I'm going to ask for from the
factory and then finally when I'm using
the factory I can just pass in the name
of the client I want in this case the
guitar client to get that particular
configured client back so that's a nice
way to kind of get started with those
illogical configurations and already it
starts to kind of layer in a little bit
of additional value the next step and
this is kind of the preferred approach
from Microsoft and probably be my
recommendation as well is to look at
using tight clients this gives us kind
of nice typed way to basically
encapsulate the logic for dealing with a
service into its own kind of class and
that's quite nice because then we can
move all of the code required for
dealing with that service to kind of a
single place and we can kind of be
honoring single responsibilities and
also this then can be registered into di
and accepted where we need it
so I'm going to first create a typed
coin and a type coin is just a class
I've named my github client it doesn't
have to implement any particular
interface as though requirements for it
to do anything there I've created my own
interface for this because when I later
inject it I want to be injecting that
the interface so that I can easily mock
this out if I want to in testing the
only thing that we have to do
specifically on a type client is accept
HTTP client in its constructor and this
is different than what we're doing
earlier where we were getting a
singleton client this will be set up for
us by the client factory so this is
going to be a new unique client instance
with or without an existing handler
chain existing connections depending if
those have expired or not and here I'm
choosing to configure the client in my
constructor we can configure type client
in the exact same way as we did with the
named client where we passed that action
into the the setup but I don't kind of
like all of that code sitting in my
configure services method and this feels
like a good place for it in my opinion
this is the this class is responsible
for dealing with github so this is where
I kind of keep my configuration for it
as well but it has the basic same effect
that we're now going to have a client
with in this class
and this is going to be a transient
class in di so we're always going to get
a new one of these as well
and then I can start creating methods
this is a method that basically does
what we were doing in the controller
previously I can give it a bit more of a
descriptive name now I can kind of
describe that this is calling for the
the repositories from the asp.net
organization and now all of the code
that was in my controller sits in here
and I feel again this is a better place
for that kind of logic controllers in my
opinion and not the place to be making
HTTP requests and trying to parse the
result the responses and deserialize
them this is kind of a nice place we're
dealing with github in here and we've
kind of encapsulated that logic and we
have one place to change this if we need
to in the future so now that I've done
that we're going to register this into
DI so I'm gonna get rid of the names
client for now and we'll just replace it
with one of the options for type 2
client so in this case because I've
chosen to have an interface I've got
I've given it a service type for my di
registration which is the the I get hub
client and then the implementation type
is our typed client that we want to
return and and that will get us going if
you wanted to do all the configuration
there you could still use the
configuration delegate in there to set
up the client the base address and
default headers so that's registered
into di so I'm now going to update my
controller yet again
and this time I'm going to accept my
github client so this has really made
the controller a little bit more
descriptive we know kind of what
services we're accepting here we know
we're going to be dealing with github
somewhere within this controller
hopefully and now I can update my action
and reduce that quite considerably and
move away all of that code that isn't
really the concern of a controller and
just call the the tied client now and so
we've we've improved the controller
we've moved the code and the logic for
dealing with github it into its own
class and that's all bound up and
handled for us in DI with the lifetime
management that we need from Haiti to be
client factory so I'll move on briefly
to outgoing middleware so I described
earlier that we kind of get this same
concept as the incoming middleware so
from an abstract point of view your
application calls htb client it makes a
request at some point over to an
endpoint and we get our response message
back but there's some stuff happening
under the HTTP client there's kind of
hidden away from us
and it's that handler chain that I keep
referring to so I haven't described the
full handler train here there's many
howlers that might be used and it
depends on things like whether you're
trying to use proxies in the requests
and things like that but at the kind of
bare-bones we have the HP client handler
that's it typically sits at this end and
the HTTP client will call in to that and
it's a bit like a it's a chain of
handlers but it's a bit like a Russian
doll model so the h-2b client handler is
the kind of outer Russian doll and then
it passes the request once it's looked
at the request it might do something
with it if it needs to but then it can
pass it into the next Russian doll
inside and continues down through the
entire handler chain until you're at the
center
that's the sockets HDB hammer this is
the one that's actually responsible for
sending packets out on the wire so this
will then issue the request and then the
response comes back in and it flows back
into that socket h2 behind that and then
back through the layers of the Russian
doll model so you get kind of two
chances to look at these requests and
responses and you can inspect them in
handlers they could potentially modify
those requests they might do nothing at
all but because we have this handler
chain we can take advantage of that by
adding our own handlers into the mix and
then we can do whatever we want here any
kind of cross-cutting concerns for
dealing with requests we can put into a
handler and that might be things like
checking for some default headers so
particularly endpoint requires headers
on every request you could do some
validation here and you could
short-circuit this flow and decide to
actually just return an immediate
response that's a failure because you
don't even need to send it over the
network in that scenario you might be
some kind of inspection or bearer tokens
and applying new bearer tokens and
authorization if that's required you
might do some kind of metrics and
monitoring around your requests and
basically once you've added these in
you're just stacking additional raus
Russian dolls around the the kind of
system hammers to do your own work and
so with this flow we can start to think
about applying those cross-cutting
concerns and hopefully simplifying our
applications where we need to do stuff
on every request the way we implement
this is using the delegating handlers as
I mentioned earlier these have existed
for some time as long as HTTP client but
with the delegating handlers you'd have
to create a handler chain and put the
handlers in the right order and then you
have to hand them off to Haiti to be
kind to make use of them and that was
that was not too bad but it could be
better and with HTTP client has been
improved so what I've got here is a
handler the only thing that I need to do
is implement will derive from the
delegating handler base class the
abstract class and then I can start to
apply the logic that I want to so this
is a really basic one I'm going to
inject a monitoring service into here
you can inject services and use them and
then I can override the send async
method which takes a request message and
a cancellation token the key line in
here is this call to await base send
async so this is the client the line
that will call the next handler in the
chain and because we've called it there
we could have done some work here before
we've passed it along in this case this
particular one looks to maybe send the
status codes that I'm getting from this
external service out to some kind of
monitoring service I'm pretending I have
here and so with this simple delegating
handler I can apply this on all requests
if I wire it up so I'm going to come
into here and I'm going to add this to
my type client definition so when we
create a named or type client what we
get back is a HIV client builder and
this allows us to chain together some
additional configuration and logic that
we want to apply when we're using that
name door tight client so in this case I
can tweet my code slightly and I'm now
going to make this call to the HTTP
client builder to add a HTTP message
handler
I can just pass it through the type of
the handler that I want to have so
without any real ceremony I've added a
hammer and I could have many handlers
here I could layer them and stack them
this will be the first handler that we
get hit and then it will call through to
any of our handlers that I decide to add
a home to this typed client
the other important thing that you have
to do is you have to make sure you
register your handler into di as a
transient service so that it can be
picked up and by HTTP client factory and
applied in the right place but with that
we've added that logic to anything that
goes through this typed client so we're
going to get all of those metrics
recorded for us we haven't got to record
that at the point of making every
request so I'm going to now talk a
little bit about poly as I say I'm not
going to sort of go into depth into
anything you could easily talk for an
hour about this I know Brian just has so
like I say check out the recording if
you want to see the details of this
but at its heart poly is a dotnet
resilience library and it allows us to
be tolerant to transient type failures
in our code it's not just for use with
HTTP client and requests you could use
it in anywhere in your application that
you want to apply these kind of policies
but HTTP request is a really good
candidate because they can have kind of
transient issues and it would be nice if
our code could deal with those in a
really simple way the poly team have
worked with the Microsoft team to
integrate this with HTTP client
factoring so there's a really nice
pattern for using this without too much
setup and basically the idea of poly is
it gives you a policy and the policy is
configured to handle some criteria so
for HTTP requests example we might
handle non-successful status codes or
HTTP requests exceptions for example and
once we've told the policy what it
handles we then apply a particular
action a particular policy that takes
effect in that scenario and there's lots
of different types the most simple and
the most regularly used is retry and
retry basically just takes a piece of
code that you want to run and execute it
multiple times if any of those
conditions occur so if you get a failure
response it can retry the request for
you and you just wrap the piece of code
that you want to run inside the policy
and it will execute with HTTP client
factory we can set these up and attach
them to all requests really easily we
don't even have to worry about modifying
the place we're making the request
so retry is common there are others
circuit breaker is another potentially
quite useful one and it allows us to
monitor for multiple failures of a
particular action so we might want to
put this across all requests to a
particular service and then we can say
if this service fails like 20 times
repeatedly there might be a bigger issue
and if we just keep hitting that with
retries and and blindly hoping that it
will come back alive we're probably just
making the problem worse
so circuit breaker lets us set that
limit and once the limits reached it
just pops open the circuit and
essentially it means that it won't let
any more requests through at that point
it basically sits open for a period of
time whatever it's configured to wait
for and then it will go to a half closed
state at the half
Oh state it will let a test message go
through and if it succeeds then it can
close the circuit and everything's
working again so it allows us to
essentially back off from that
downstream system that may be struggling
the roller things like we can apply
additional time outs to execution in a
code bulkhead isolation is quite an
interesting one and slightly harder to
explain but the basic idea is to try and
reduce the possibility of a cascading
failure situation so if you're talking
to a struggling downstream system and
it's either backing up requests or it's
continually failing and we're continuing
continually retrying creep the debt will
add more loads to your service it's
going to have to make more requests it's
going to have to handle more exceptions
and that can have a resource issue on
your system that may actually bring your
application code down as well so
bulkhead basically lets you put a limit
on a concurrent activity so you could
say for talking to a particular set of
services you might put them into this
bulkhead that means a certain number of
requests can be handled at once and if
the limits reached and it also has a
queue which could be reached then it
would just stop accepting things so it
lets you stop using all of your
resources to talk to a particular
downstream system and hopefully stops a
cascading failure effect
there's caching policies that you can
apply this for backed which you can take
effect if all other attempts have failed
maybe you just want to return some kind
of default and we can combine these
together with the idea of a policy wrap
and typically we would at least combine
like retries and circuit breakers and
maybe fall backs to give us a policy
that overall will handle all of the
situations we might expect from making
HTTP requests so this is quite briefly
what the retry looks like and this is
our application at the top there's a
downstream service it's on fire they're
not having a great day we make the
request message and we get back a 503
which is probably quite optimistic if
there's a fire but still we've got a 503
and what are we going to do in this
situation we can we can fail and we can
we can just return a bad request to our
caller maybe we have some of our own
retry logic that we have to implement
and that's code that we have to write
that makes a retry attempt of its own
with poly we just create the policy up
front that says okay if I get 500 phrase
I'm going to retry and you can retry up
to two times so the first request occurs
comes back as a 503 poly kicks in and
goes yeah I can handle favor free I'm
gonna react to keep that request for you
comes in it's still failing and between
the first and second requests someone
puts out the fire pretty good job poly
kicks in we get a retry and this time we
get the 200 so in this situation
although we may have delayed slightly
the response to our caller we've been
able to handle the fact that that
service was temporarily unavailable the
fire is a bit of a joke example but
typically you know services are failing
over in cloud environments or if you're
running services and containers they may
momentarily not be available in low
balance may not send traffic to them
this kind of situation may recover that
kind of situation so how can we do this
with poly and HTTP client Factory so
with the HP comment builder we can apply
additional extension method in here now
this is not available by default with
the asp.net core app package what you
have to do is bring in the Microsoft
extension store HTTP door poly package
so Microsoft don't include by default
any third-party dependencies where they
can avoid it you have to explicitly add
that package fine you get just through
that you can start using the poly
integration piece of this and that gives
us access to methods like as transient
HTTP error policy and in this an example
what it's going to do is it's going to
preset us up a policy builder instance
and on that policy builder we're going
to get back a pre-configured policy
that's going to handle potential
transient type issues so 500 accept
requests codes for r8 timeout or HTTP
request exceptions any of those
scenarios it will consider itself active
and therefore it will implement the
policy that you define so once you've
got the builder you can then use it to
set up the policy you want to apply in
this scenario I'm going to use a weight
and a retry so just doing a retry
immediately is kind of pointless in most
situations giving it a millisecond or
two will probably not mean the
downstream system is recovered so it's
good to kind of give it a little bit of
a wait time before you do it in this
scenario I'm saying well rate to three
retries up to three retries if you need
and in here I can use this kind of code
to apply an exponential back-off so this
runs at the time that it's doing the
retry and we have the retry count so we
can use it to calculate and a longer
back off period because the more retries
you do the least likelihood that the
downstream system is going to recover
quickly and so giving it that little bit
of extra time might just get you over
that problem so that's added it in and
that's what we have to do any requests
that now go through that typed client
they're going to apply that policy
automatically and that means that we've
kind of just get the benefit without
having to adjust any of our request code
at all now we can also do things like
dynamically apply policies the reason we
might want to do this will become
evident in a moment but what I'm going
to do is to find two policies just using
the poly api's and I'm not really going
to go into these in detail but the first
is a no op policy so this just looks
like a policy act like a policy but does
nothing so it executes the code once and
that's it the retry is just the same as
what we did before but this time I'm
manually creating this using the poly
extensions and so now I have two
policies available to me and then in
this code I can use the add policy
Handler over extension method with an
overload that lets me inspect the
request message so the way poly
integrations work is it basically
creates a delegating handler does that
suffice to do cross-cutting concerns and
then it wraps the the call to the base
don't send async in the policy but
before it wraps it we have the
possibility of looking the requests
message and inspecting things on it so
in this case I'm doing a conditional
policy by saying if it's a get then
retry it if it's any other action type
HTTP method type sorry then apply the no
op now the reason we might want to do
this is because if we're talking to a
downstream system retrying again should
be safe it should have no side-effects
it should be an idempotent operation and
so we can we can do that fairly safely
but if we're talking to a downstream
system with a pert supposed a patch of
delete those typically could have some
side-effects and what we don't know is
that our original request didn't get to
the to the endpoint we're talking to so
in that scenario we could send say in
order to an order entry system it might
receive it it might store it and then
the response that it sends to us may
just not reach us for some reason some
kind of transient network issue and so
therefore we all timeout in that
scenario if I haven't got a conditional
policy it would just apply a retry there
what happens if I send out over twice if
we control the system it might be okay
but if it's a third party service maybe
they duplicate the order maybe they just
accept it and realize that it's a
duplicate and ignore that who knows so
this kind of thing can allow us to do
inspection before we apply the policies
you can inspect anything on that request
message you could apply this
conditionally to different paths maybe
you want to use headers as a way of
turning this on and off so you could
maybe have a no retry header that you
send through on certain requests and it
will automatically avoid putting that
policy on to your request for you the
final piece I want to show with poly is
the poly registry this was a feature
that I kind of helped request because I
was using the policy registry and I
wanted to find out how we would kind of
interface the two and so the simplest
example of this is I'm going to create
two timeout policies I did those just
because they're really short so I've got
to timeout policies of different lengths
and then I want to use a policy registry
and this is just a store for policies
it's basically a dictionary under the
hood but it allows us to create those
policies once and then reuse them across
the application and that's how policies
are sort of intended to be used the
thread safe and reusing the means we've
allocated that that policy once some
policies like circuit breaker expect to
be shared so with a registry this is one
place that we can register them upfront
and then whenever we need them we can
just access them from the registry so
I'm going to call this add policy
registry method what that's going to do
is register the registry into di and
then it gives us back a reference so
that I can continue setting this up so
now I can just add my my two policies in
there giving them a name and now when I
set up my type client what I could do is
say add policy handler from registry and
has passed the name so if I've got lots
of tight clients for lots of different
endpoints this is a shorter way for me
to define those once and start reusing
them and are the final thing on HP
client factory that I've included this
because a lot of people ask a question
about this is what about situations
where you were traditionally setting up
a handler I hate to be client handler
with things like certificates or proxy
configurations and things like
you can do it with httpclient factory
you just need to tell it how to
configure that primary hammer so in here
we have the full responsibility for
creating the top-level h-2b client
handler that would be used in this
scenario this is still under lifetime
management so the typed client we're
using here will still keep that for two
minutes and then use a different one but
it uses this an actual piece of code to
kind of set up the handler and attach it
so that HTTP client is going to give you
where I go too deep into that code but
just be aware that that's there if you
have those more advanced configuration
needs so want to move on from HTTP
client factory and just try and group
together some other HTTP tips from sort
of various sources that i've i've bend
from reading lots of information talking
to various people at the Microsoft teams
and watching other talks and things the
first one is to take care when you
handle response content so what do I
mean by that so in our method here I've
got these two lines at the bottom which
are dealing with reading the content and
then basically passing it into Jason net
so we can deserialize the JSON and
string the problem with this piece of
code is this first line we're basically
reading the entire content into a string
and allocating a string for that content
and then we pass it into Jason's on that
now the problem with that is we're going
to have a lot of allocations of strings
here and if the response content big
which it could be if it's a big array of
JSON data if that was big enough it
could push it into the large object heap
even and so we're gonna have a lot of
allocations that could have a
performance impact in our code because
that's all going to be managed by the
garbage collector and if it goes into
the large object heap you have a whole
other set of issues around the potential
for compaction there so basically this
string is redundant because all we're
doing is is passing interjections on
there but Jason's Ornette supports
deserializing from streams natively so
we should probably use a stream for this
now I could write all of that code
manually it's not a huge amount of code
but the much simpler option is to use
the read out string async method this
isn't part of h-2b kind of a default but
there's a Microsoft package in the Web
API doc client package but and that
gives us access to these additional
extension methods and this one just
takes the type that we expect to
deserialize into and under the hood it
will use the JSON nets
features so that we can actually avoid
that additional allocation there was a
small issue with this in terms of like
debugging experience because some people
want to be able to debug here and
inspect the string kind of just have to
deal with that you could include it
temporarily and try and remember to take
it out or you could if debug it or
whatever but this is a much better
option for avoiding a potential of
attack vector as well so if the client
the service that we're talking to was
kind of taken over they could just
return for fun a 10 gig string of data
in that content and we just tried to
read that into a string so that's an
attack vector we want to try and avoid
and at least pausing it over the stream
we realize it's not what we're looking
for and hopefully it will allocate a
little less next up is handling errors
so we talked about poly in terms of
handling transient HTTP network errors
server errors but the other kind of
error is obviously that we may get the
response back but it might signify an
hour
400 or 404 I'm not handling that here
I'm just trying to deserialize the
content that may not even be there into
this this on your github repo so we
should always handle that here I'm just
going to use the response to ensure
success status code so this will just
run through the code check if it's a 200
range status code and if it is continue
otherwise it throws an exception so in
this case the corner of this method has
to handle that exception and be ready
for it another option
probably my preferred option is to try
and not for exceptions there so instead
I'm just going to check is the success
status code property on there if it is
then I do get my deserialization
otherwise I return because some kind of
default it's up to you what's kind of
correct for the context you're working
in here and what you might want to do
but do make sure you're in some form
checking for that before you just pass
the code on I have some things blow up
just purely because they're trying to
read content that isn't there the next
tip is is handling cancellation so avoid
doing work you don't need to do so
someone starts an activity and then kind
of gives up on you
you don't want to continue doing a bunch
of work for them and that could include
things like making HTTP requests that
could be expensive operations so the way
we're going to do this in our type
client is first I'm going to accept I
canceled a
touken into my method this is just a
standard way with async/await of dealing
with cancellation to cancellation
scenarios so I've got my cancellation
token so I can do a few things
potentially what I could do is quickly
fail if they quickly cancel this before
we've even started making the request
let's get out for an exception and move
on but we can also pass it through to
any of the async methods like send a
seeing readers async so that they will
cancel their activity as well if it's
signaled the problem we're going to have
though is how we pass that in we're
calling this from a controller something
that quite a lot of people don't seem to
be aware of because it's not necessarily
pushed that heavily is that controllers
can accept a cancellation token and the
framework will give you this
automatically so when it activates the
controller and it activates the method
it will just attach a cancellation token
that's tied to the current request that
it's dealing with and that means that if
someone closes the browser or gives up
on a request they've made to you you'll
get signified that that's happened and
then we can pass that through so now we
can avoid doing additional work if
people have stopped calling us the next
tip is caching this is another thing
that could be easily is its own talk its
own hour I'm going to kind of give you
the general view of it and a couple of
pointers but there's a lot more to this
that you'll have to consider given
different situations you'll be running
into but let's say I want to use caching
in this application so the easy option
for me here is just use the asp.net core
memory cache as a simple option this
would work in a kind of single instance
application if you were doing something
that's kind of real and you've got
multiple containers running this service
you probably want to use distributed
caching but memory cache was a little
easier to show so I've added that in
I've got that service available in this
application I can inject now the eye
memory cache into the tight client to
start taking advantage your weapon and
then I'm going to update my methods
slightly there's a couple of kind of key
changes here so the first that might not
look immediately familiar is the bottom
part if you haven't seen this is c-sharp
seven probably oh but I'm not sure but
it's local functions it's local methods
and it's basically a way to put a method
inside a method where it's contextually
sensible to do so
so traditionally I would have used maybe
a private method on the class for this
but in this case it's really tied to
this first method anyway and I don't
other people within the class calling it
from other other methods in this class
so this way are basically kind of hidden
it inside the first method and it looks
like a normal method I can call it in
the right way that can be defined
anywhere in this piece this method but
I've just put it towards the bottom
which is my preference and then I'm
using the memory cache
I'm calling the get or create a sync
method on there I need to pass a cache
key something to identify this by and
then what it's going to do is if the
cache item is there it just returns it
and that's the end of the day we haven't
made any HTTP requests we've avoided
work we've avoided load on our system
and the downstream system if not it will
set up an entry with a five-minute
timeout and then just run that that
local function to make the requests that
we were doing before there's so many
ways you could apply caching poly has
its own caching policy I've never found
that one of the most trendy to use and
there are some gotchas you want to
potentially apply that maybe on your
tight client and in that case what you'd
actually be caching is for all HTTP
request messages you'd be cashing their
actual HTTP response message for that
particular message there are some read
once or certainly you have to rewind
them streams on the content you get back
on the response message so sticking that
thing into the cache could have problems
for the second person that actually gets
it out of the cache there's also work to
do with that response we have to check
if this a success code and deserialize
it there's not much point doing that
time and time again so I prefer to kind
of cache a little bit higher up here at
the point of making the request but you
could just as easily use any other
technique here you could apply a caching
policy from poly to do this slightly
differently if you wanted to so kind of
coming towards the end but I'm going to
start just talking about a few bonus
tips so the first is this concept that I
read on dummy buyers post on his blog
that at least privileged he credits it
back to at random Ponte there's probably
like a chain of people that have
mentioned it but it's the idea of using
extension methods so as a library author
you want to write some kind of SDK that
allows people to communicate with your
API and you want to kind of do that in a
really nice way how do you know how
they're going to handle HTTP client you
don't necessarily want
handle httpclient yourself because you
haven't necessarily got a good system
for doing that particular if you're a
dotnet standard library you don't know
if you're running on dotnet core that
PHP client Factory might not be
available if it is you don't want to
force it on them so one option that
Dominic buyer was looking at for the
kind of the identity service stuff was
maybe just create extension methods to
what you need to do this I liked the
idea and I've used it in a couple of
places so I'm going to create some
extensions I've got an extension method
this is basically doing what we've been
doing before in the actual type decline
I've made it a little bit more general
now so I can accept the organisation
name into this method and then the rest
of the code is basically the same as
before and now I'm just going to make
the appropriate crash using that
particular all name but imagine now this
isn't a library I'm going to bring that
library into my application so instead
of writing this code myself I'm just
going to use this library that I've been
given so I would just call the the get
repos async extension method on the HTTP
client and I've controlled the creation
of the client I've used typed client and
HTTP client Factory but the method could
be provided to me but in a very
generalized way by someone else that's
just quite a nice thing that I saw when
reading through some stuff that I
thought it was worth sharing the second
bonus tip is around using correlation
IDs this is less about like good HTTP
requests practice and more about
avoiding a world of pain with
distributed systems we've built a bunch
of micro services and magics and they're
all talking to one another some of its
async and we're doing stuff over queues
and events but certain times we're
making HTTP requests cause we need data
immediately and if something fails down
the stream it's quite useful to be able
to tie that all together and so using a
correlation ID from the very first entry
point into an activity stream in your
context of your kind of application or
distributed app apply a unique ID
to it somehow and then make sure you
pass that through using correlation IDs
I don't have code examples of this but
I've got a small library up on nuget
which basically allows you to do this
and what it will do in an asp.net core
application you can add this in it will
add some middleware that will inspect
the headers it will look for a
particular correlation ID header and
that's configurable of course
and once it gets that header it can have
combatant Lee give us a context that we
can flow through the rest of that
request and then we could pass that on
on to any outgoing requests that we're
making with the HTTP client and the way
I've tended to do that in the past is to
use a delegating howler to do that it's
a cross-cutting concern on all requests
so just have the delegating hand I have
access to that context that's got the
correlation ID and make sure it attaches
the appropriate headers because we can
modify those requests in the outgoing
process of those delegating handler
chains so that's just worth kind of
keeping in mind the libraries there if
you want to use it the asp.net team have
been working on various solutions kind
of tracing and things as well so I think
they have their own activity IDs and
things you can look at using but I wrote
this kind of before that was all
available so the final kind of area that
I want to look at is just some other
well this other improvement that was
available in dotnet core 2.1 that it's
worth knowing is available and kind of
in place
so before 2.1 the way the kind of the
end of that handler chain would work is
when you got to the end of the handler
it would use os-level api's for making
HTTP requests so basically there was a
split path where you had over a kind of
Windows approach or a Linux Mac approach
and on the windows side if it was
running on a Windows platform it would
use a handler that called down to the
win HTTP API is to actually issue the
HTTP requests it was using a lip curl on
Linux and the main problem that the team
had with this was that actually there
was a big performance drift in the tulip
Cole and the integration there was not
anywhere near as close in terms of frupa
and a lot of us now if we're building
kind of micro services we're deploying
them into docker we're deploying them on
Linux containers and so this has a
performance implication for applications
so what the team decided to do is to
kind of rethink things and they've
rewritten all of the logic and the
actual code for making HTTP requests as
managed c-sharp code and they've used
the sockets API to actually kind of just
create a raw socket onto the OS to
actually send the data over the wire so
they fought in all of the kind of HTTP
piece of that into manage code so this
is good because now they have a kind of
consistent code base they have
control later how that works and it's
something the team are continuing to
work on in terms of them performance but
when they did this they got much closer
to parity between Windows and Linux in
terms of making those requests and
that's that was a free gain just by
upgrading to 2.1 if you were making lots
of outgoing requests you've got that
performance boost by default because it
switched on in 2.1 by default if you
can't use it and there are a few reasons
why you won't one is if you need to use
HTTP to on those outgoing requests
because they haven't built that piece
yet then you would have to switch it off
and you just do that with an environment
variable but unless you have a specific
need to do so don't turn it off because
you're just slowing your app down for no
reason and the team have continued to
work on this feature as well so in the
2.2 release
I think they reported another 60 percent
performance increase are doubling the
kind of improve improvement on requests
on linux and i think it was 20% on
Windows so there's much sort of gain to
be got there and that's from some of the
other performance improvement work with
span and things like that that the team
are doing and I'm sure there will be
continued investment to getting this as
quick as possible because it's a common
story that people are using this feature
set so we're kind of coming towards the
end and I'm just going to summarize and
just try and let the information sink in
that final time before everyone runs for
beers we if you're using net core to put
one specifically very of asp.net core
2.1 then do use the HTTP client factory
feature it's there for a reason it makes
life easier and the key thing is that
lifetime management if you don't want to
worry about ty clients and name clients
and figuring all that stuff out then you
don't have to from day one just convert
your existing app make sure it's
registered as a service and then switch
over to using the HP client factory to
give you your client instances but once
you've got that going it's roll of time
looking at factoring stuff into typed
baiance in my opinion that's the kind of
recommended story from the team it's
going to make your testing easier
because you're generally in places where
you're consuming those things you're now
just testing a typed client interface
that you might have and you can just
test that type client once if you need
to so just switch that one
if you
Anette call 2.10 if you want to use it
you still can you just have to bring in
that Microsoft or extensions HTTP
package if you're using doing any kind
of kind of work that could fail then I
recommend bringing in poly it's great
for other situations as well you might
want to use it for talking to database
services or other internal services but
it really works well with HTTP
situations and particularly well with
HTTP client Factory in the mix really do
be aware of that read a string async
getstring async unnecessary allocations
expecting handle errors from the
services you're talking to 400s 404 is
that kind of thing make sure you're
dealing with those appropriately do you
try and look at parsing translation
tokens through any asynchronous work and
particularly in this scenario to avoid
maybe making requests that you don't
need to counseling them when the
activity has been cancelled in advance
cache wisely you know think about what
your caching think about how long your
caching it for and you know the caching
technology of the right is the right
choice you know you could just still
fill up the memory on your local machine
if you just use a memory cache like you
know quickly appropriate limits in place
I think Damon and David sort of cooled
out just kind of unbounded caches as
being a kind of risk for asp net core
applications in their talk pass
correlation ids through your your
services easy way to do that with HTTP
client is just to do it on headers
between requests and then just pick them
up on the other end but ultimately just
kind of go and enjoy doing some HTTP
hopefully these tips have been useful
thank you very much for listening please
do leave feedback on your way out it
really does help me understand if this
is kind of hit the mark if you're
putting yellows and reds in and you're
not too scared to come and talk to me
and tell me why you put a yellow in a
reading that would be really useful
because I can make this better for the
next time I do it if you want to sort of
reach out at Steve J Gordon on Twitter
my blog which has gone as soon as I say
a lot of articles on HTTP client factory
I've got another one coming on how to
test in that scenario as well and some
resources for use we kind of take away
another these are included in the slide
deck but if you want to have them now do
you take a shot so the slide deck itself
is on that link another plug for the
blog and check that out the asp.net
monsters post is kind of one of the
first blog post that talks about the
kind of socket exhaustion issue the eye
sore at least so if you want a bit more
detail on that story you can go check
out their postings here it's kind of
couple years olds this hasn't this has
kind of been around as long as kind of
dominate cause been around as a
potential issue the official
documentation I think it's quite good
that I wrote it so I'm biased but check
it out see if that helps answer the
questions and then check out my blog for
some deeper examples poly you can go
check out this like they've got a really
great wiki so if you're trying to
integrate Pauline you're trying to work
out how to build the various policies
the wikis were really really good and
then that post by and Dominic bio that I
mentioned as well so I'll leave those up
I kind of got five minutes if people
have any questions they want to yell out
otherwise I'll hang around and I'll be
down kind of near somewhere with beer
after this haha I had this conversation
today so I wasn't entirely short so the
question is if the HP request is an HTTP
response message implement I disposable
and the reason they do that is if you're
you're using streams on the content the
answer I've been given by Ryan I'm not
sure if Ryan's in here
but Ryan Nowak from the Microsoft team
did HP client factory I was trying to
kind of get a definitive on this it kind
of depends but if you create the stream
that's reading off of there then you're
responsible for kind of clearing that
stuff up so you could use the user put a
using statement around your response or
request there I think of you using the
Microsoft kind of reader string async
you're kind of okay because they deal
with the streams lower down but if
you're not sure you could put it on I
did have some slides anywhere I showed
doing it and I've taken them out on the
on the basis that I think it's probably
not necessarily always required so the
team so the question is any anything
else coming in dotnet called free oh
I've kind of vaguely followed it the key
things that the team were looking at do
with HTTP client factory is some
additional work on trying to integrate
with the poly metrics and monitoring if
they can so as and when that's ready in
the poly library
myself when we apply these policies we
can find out like how many times things
have retried and get some way of getting
that information back out and so once
that's ready from Poli then hopefully
the team will find a nice solution for
integrating that into what we're doing
as well I haven't seen any other major
changes I suspect some more performance
gains hopefully as a sort of a con going
effort that they're making there yeah
all right yeah I can potentially
[Music]
yeah I did yeah I didn't there's some
recommendation about not applying it
where you don't need to so that you
don't it's not there by default so you'd
have to actually ask for that service to
be registered in to do I if you want to
get it into places where it's not
naturally available so I kind of just
avoided using it for that reason that I
didn't want to force someone's have to
have that correlation context so I've
used a sinc local to create my own
correlation context but it's much more
lightweight because it's only just kind
of carrying a couple of things around so
yeah I'm gonna tell you sure if it's the
right choice at the time but it felt
like a good way of avoiding people
having that additional dependency anyone
else yes so the question is is there a
plan to bring FTP client or something
similar and my ultras I have no idea I'm
afraid no okay thank you very much
[Applause]